what is the secret to Tarantino dialogue  I just get the characters talking to  each other so it's like me the writer is  writing it and yeah I'm kind of  controlling it for a while but the idea  is the conversation catches fire amongst  the characters who said Dan's dead baby  it's dead and then they take it and run  with it and then I'm almost like a court  reporter jotting it all down and then  usually whatever comes out is what comes  out now inside of that there's a rhythm  to it there is a musicality to it there  is a bit of rhyme that happens between  some of the words and some of the  phrases are you gonna bark all day  little doggy or are you gonna bite and  so you know it's not poetry but it's not  completely divorced from poetry it's not  rap but it's not completely divorced  from it it's not a stand-up comedy act  but it's not completely divorced from  that either  that's a bingo